well Iraq and Syria are rebuilding their
relations Iraq's prime minister is the
first Iraqi leader to visit Damascus
since the start of the Syrian Civil War
in 2011. Syrian president Bashar Assad
greeted Muhammad Shia al-sudani among
issues being discussed are strengthening
economic ties and the security of their
shared border it's the latest sign of
improving Regional relations Syria was
also recently readmitted to the Arab
League after a 12-year suspension well
let's bring in our correspondent
he's in Baghdad and he joins us live now
Mahmoud as we were saying this is the
first official visit by an Iraqi leader
to Syria in 13 years talk us through the
significance
Wellness tells you the significance of
this visit it lies in the fact that both
leaders seem to be Keen to build on its
momentum to break the isolation uh both
countries have suffered from uh for
years as you know that this is the first
visit by an Iraqi leader to Syria since
2010 then since the the last visit by a
former prime minister Nori al-maliki as
you know that Iraq wants to bring back
home it's a good relationships its
comprehensive relationships with its
neighbors and also Iraq was one of the
first countries to support the Syrian
government and the return of Syria to
the Arab League and the participation of
Syria in the Arab Summit in Jeddah last
May as you know that both governments
are backed by uh the same Ally in the
region by Iran on and Iraq wants also to
support the Syrian government as it did
in the last or the seventh conference on
supporting Syria and the region that was
held in Brussels in June as you know
that Iraq has been always one of the
strongest backers of the Syrian regime
and also Iraq has been always calling on
the International Community to lift
sanctions in Syria and also to
facilitate the entry of AIDS to the
Syrian people so it seemed that both
leaders Bashar al-assad and Muhammad
Sudani are Keen to build on the momentum
of this visit to break the isolation
other countries have been suffering from
well clearly some strong Optics here but
what are the most important issues the
two leaders will coverage you think
well definitely mutual interests and
mutual challenges facing both countries
as you know that terrorism on top of the
agenda and the infiltration of Terror
elements on the border as you know that
600 kilometers is the border line
between Syria and Iraq the infiltration
of terrorism drug trafficking people
trafficking smuggling the issue also
pertaining to a major concern for both
countries which is water as you know
that the Euphrates river which goes
through Syria and into Iraq and that
stems from Turkey both countries have
major concerns over what they call the
damning programs by turkey which has
halted major parts of the water flows
into both countries and that has
resulted in serious ramifications in
both countries especially with climate
change and with
scorching summer temperatures also the
issue of security as you know that both
countries they have armored groups in
the north of both countries engaging in
conflict with turkey so addressing they
want to address turkey on both issues on
the water issue on the security issue as
well last but not least the refugees a
whole camp in Syria and the Iraqi
refugees in Syria so they also want as
the prime minister of Iraq mentioned
during the press conference that they
want to enhance economic and trade
relationships between the two countries
and also to
re-gain the comprehensive relations
between the two countries in the region
across that visit for us from Baghdad
thank you Mahmoud well let's now bring
in Marwan kabalan he's the head of
policy analysis at the Arab Center for
research and policy studies Marwan great
to have you back with us thank you it's
been really quite the Diplomatic
comeback hasn't it for president Assad
I do recall though even during the war
senior Iraqi officials did maintain some
relations with with his regime I think
you have to differentiate between
two phases in the relationship between
the two countries from
2011. the first one under mural Maliki
the relationship was was good because
the two countries the two regimes they
believed that they were fighting the
same war against isil against other
armed groups but then when Maliki
actually left office and hyderabadi
became prime minister the relationship
between the two countries started to
cool down a little bit because the
American pressure on the Iraqi
government
actually was important on one hand and
Iran did not have enough influence over
hyderabadi but now because the pro-iran
forces are back empowered in Iraq so we
can see that the Iraqi prime minister is
coming is coming back actually to visit
Damascus and have this sort of
improvement in the relationship between
between the two countries so it's
important but it's not surprising as
the borrow Iran forces are now in power
in Baghdad sure well even if we go back
a few decades Iraq was much more
complicated than relationships much more
complicated
absolutely the the bath party was ruling
in the two countries in Baghdad and in
Damascus and the two wings of the bath
party were like a very tough uh uh uh
confrontation over who is the legitimate
representative of the of the baptism in
the Arab in the Arab world so the
relationship was very difficult at that
time between Saddam Hussein and half as
Assad but then I mean you know after the
U.S invasion of Iraq and uh the tubbling
of the Saddam Hussein regime the
formation of the Iraqi government by
Iran forces and Iran is supporting
Bashar as on the other hand so that
actually brought the two countries
closer together but that did not mean
also that there were no difficulties in
the relationship between the two
countries because nurul Maliki for
example in 2009 he accused the regime of
President Bashar Assad of
plotting the so-called in Iraq the black
Wednesday in which a Car Bomb actually
went off in front of the Iraqi Finance
finance ministry leading to the uh
leading more than 300 people killed so
America at that time accused Syria of
actually blotting that and he went to
the United Nations to call for
establishing a special tribunal in order
to uh to bring the the Syrian government
accountable to that but then when when
when the revolution started in Syria in
2011 everything changed and Syria and
Iraq believed that they were fighting
the same enemy Iran put pressure on the
two and the two sides in order to come
together and and form what they called I
United the front against uh extremists
and of course they share a 600 kilometer
long border I imagine the White House
will be watching today's events very
closely absolutely I think the
the main issue in the visit by by Sudani
today is border security because this is
something really
important for I mean for both countries
but mainly for for Iraq uh of course I
mean the two countries will be trying
actually to develop their economic
relationship but then we have the U.S
sanctions on Syria that will make it
difficult for any Iraqi government to
develop the economic relationship with
the with Damascus uh in a in a
meaningful way so we don't expect much
improvement actually here but I think
we'll see more coordination on the on on
border security and also on the issue of
water as your correspondent mentioned
during reporting from from Baghdad the
two countries are suffering from water
shortages because turkey is not getting
enough water turkey is controlling the
the sources of the authorities and
degrees the two main rivers flowing down
into Syria and into Iraq as well and
really quite the statement such a high
level visit Marwan kabulan there the
head of policy analysis at the Arab
Center for research and policy studies
always great to chat to you Marwan
thanks for joining us again thank you
for having me